aujourd'hui mercredi 8 juillet 2015
bonsoir et bienvenue sur tv fil 78
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction voici les titres
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines cadre d'une expérimentation de
bus électrique ce test grandeur nature
pourrait permettre en cas de succès une
généralisation et du service à
l'ensemble de l'île de france la
préfecture des yvelines qui rénove son
hall d'accueil
au delà du changement esthétique de
table quels seront les plus pour les
usagers et puis là trois millions
d'enfants ne partent pas en vacances
pendant l'été les communes multiplie les
activités pour les distraire exemple à
elancourt et attrapes avec nos invités
qui nous donneront les grandes lignes de
leur programmation
c'est donc une première dans la grande
couronne la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ski bus
cette société ont décidé de tester
pendant deux jours un bus électrique sur
l'une des lignes à la ligne 430 et une
aile c'est un projet qui pourrait
permettre de faire des économies de
carburant tout en protégeant bien
évidemment l'environnement
le reportage est signée michael et demi
d'euros et william l la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en partenariat avec la société
ski bus a testé pour la toute première
fois un service de bus électrique le
véhicule à circuler sur la ligne 4 131
entre trappe et il encourt on fait
vraiment une phase de test puisque
jusqu'à présent les tests de bus
électriques étaient réservées à paris
paris intramuros et donc ont appelé
initiative avec ski bus avec
l'agglomération de se rapprocher d'une
entreprise qui fait des minibus
électriques une entreprise francilienne
qui en seine-et-marne pour faire ce test
pendant deux jours pour voir si
effectivement cette technologie est
adaptée dans certaines circonstances
bien précises au contexte de saint
quentin en yvelines
le bus a tourné à vide sur la journée de
mardi aujourd'hui des voyages auront pu
emprunter ce véhicule électrique
si le test est concluant la ligne
pourraient être équipés de bus
électriques dans les prochains mois on
va recueillir effectivement la vie des
voyageurs sur cette ligne
journée on fera un bilan ensuite et si
ce bilan est positif on se rapprochera
ensuite du stif pour voir dans quelles
conditions et éventuellement sur la
grande couronne où on pourrait avoir
puisque on serait les premiers contre
corona avoir une ligne exploité en bus
électrique un bus électriques coûtent en
moyenne 500 mille euros contre 245
milles pour un bus roulant au diesel
la consommation du véhicule est réduite
par trois le hall d'accueil de la
préfecture va rouvrir après des travaux
de plus d'un nom une réouverture à
partir du 1er septembre avec des
modifications d'accueil pour le public
les explications de catherine mulato à
nouveau le plus spacieux 3,2 millions
d'euros pour le haut de la préfecture le
but mieux accueillir le public et
réorganiser les services pour que les
usagers ne soient pas toujours obligé de
se déplacer en préfecture
l'accent a aussi été mis sur
l'augmentation des services en ligne la
possibilité aussi de recevoir
directement sur son téléphone par sms un
message d'information lui disant par
exemple votre titre est arrivé votre
carte d'identité votre permis de
conduire est arrivé prenez rendez vous
sur internet
l'objectif donc réduire le nombre
d'usagers en préfecture et donc de
passage inutile par exemple 250
personnes viennent quotidiennement pour
des questions de permis de conduire ou
de cartes grises avant l'usagé se
présenter dans le but d'obtenir son
certificat d'immatriculation et de
repartir avec
maintenant que ce n'est plus fabriqué en
préfecture non plus on propose à l'usagé
de déposer son dossier par la voie
postale
alors avec l'aide du site internet où on
a des fiches autocontrôle pour l'aider à
constituer son dossier est effectivement
lorsque nous allons traiter sa demande
est bien l' agence nationale des titres
sécurisés envoie directement le titre
par voie postale au domicile de l'usager
donc il n'y a vraiment plus aucun
bénéfice pour que l'usagé d'une perdre
du temps en préfecture pour les
étrangers un guichet unique du demandeur
d'asile sera mis en place à l'automne
là encore le but simplifier les
démarches et pour accompagner cette
réouverture au 1er septembre cinq jeunes
en service civique sont en cours de
recrutement
ils auront pour vocation d'assurer le
premier accueil et si vous souhaitez
vous rendre en préfecture ou dans l'une
des sous préfectures des yvelines sachez
qu'elles seront fermés
lundi 13 juillet veille de fête
nationale réouverture annoncée le 15 aux
horaires habituels nous allons à présent
parler des vacances vos loisirs pour cet
été avec lé programme notamment dans
deux communes trappe et et long cours
bonsoir a b x vous êtes maire adjoint la
trappe en charge de la jeunesse et des
sports et bonsoir anne capio vous êtes
maire adjoint à elancourt en charge de
l'éducation notamment avant de regarder
ce qui va se passer ce qui va se
dérouler dans vos villes un micro
trottoir c'est notre question du jour
comment allez vous occuper vos vacances
à la plage on va en vain randonnée ont
fait du vélo ont l'âge ont fait que
lebron james à plage
il part en vacances en bretagne à moi en
vacances je vais faire du voile et je
veux aller un look tôt conscient tout ce
qui est bateau j'aime bien du foot
cette volée ans à aller dehors mais
beaucoup de livres pendant les vacances
surtout des serait là moi pour les
vacances je vois des amis je profite de
pas avoir à travailler je vais partir en
colo cette année parce que ça me permet
de partir loin pour pas trop cher donc
s'en va au bronzage piscine plage et
lectures et ce sera fiesta aussi pour la
fin mais voilà selon l'institut de
sondage csa l'activité préférée des
français pendant les vacances les
balades à 33% dormir aussi c'est une
belle activité à 15% égalité avec les
visites de sites culturels tout de même
votre activité préférée à chacun pendant
les vacances dans l'île
dormir ne me suis pas beaucoup
l'occasion de partie des 15 % et la mer
la mer la mer profiter de la mer avant
tout au delà de ce clin d'oeil la
réalité de la période estivale c'est
également un peu moins sourions cette
année encore près de 3 millions
d'enfants ne partiront pas en vacances
ils ont entre 5 et 19 ans et d'ici au
mois de septembre il a bien falloir leur
permettre de s'évader a aussi attrapé
l'encours donc des activités proposées
on va commencer par l encours des
rendez-vous qui sont proposées du côté
de la clé de saint pierre ce sera
centralisé sur ce quartier notamment
d'accord alors donc effectivement à
elancourt beaucoup de d'animation sont
organisés gratuite et ludique pour pour
pour tous les enfants
donc en dehors des centres de loisirs
qui sont ouverts pour pour les 3 11 ans
il y a effectivement un point d'accueil
animations au centre champollion
au stade de boniface où il y aura
l'accueil des enfants des adolescents de
11 à 17 ans avec des sorties au bowling
à lille de loisirs skywest daïra du
kayak à l'île des loisirs
on accueille à peu près 60 jeunes par
jour sur ce dispositif là du lundi au
vendredi il y a également au complexe
sportif europe à la clé saint-pierre du
tennis de table on a passé un
partenariat avec le club de tennis de
table
donc il y aura des séances de 14h à 18h
en juillet et en août et sur ce
dispositif on accueille entre 20 et 30
jeunes implication des services de la
ville des associations aussi alors
l'implication des services de la ville
des animateurs des animateurs de la
ville et un partenariat avec
l'association du tennis de table qui
donc va accueillir et encadrer tous ces
jeunes
voilà c'est tout à l'heure il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui ne partent pas en
vacances j'imagine que c'est difficile
de les comptabiliser sur la commune mais
vous devez avoir tout même une idée est
ce que c'est les deux mondes sont fortes
est ce que justement c'est aussi
important pour une municipalité
d'intervenir et et de pouvoir occuper
tous ces jeunes
alors oui il ya beaucoup de jeunes
effectivement ce dispositif accueille
soixante jeunes en gros un sur la clé
saint piat quant aux séances de tennis
de table c'est environ entre 20 et 30
jeunes par jour
donc ça fait à peu près une centaine 150
jeunes je dirais sur l'ensemble de la
ville par jour il ya aussi un autre pôle
sur la clé simplet roule assez regroupés
sur la place de paris où il ya des
activités de proposer des jeux de grands
jeux en bois ou à des jeux géants en
bois et ce genre ce genre d'activités
qui sont qui sont proposés en dehors de
ça on a la chance d'avoir france
miniature sur la ville où les gens y
vont une nouvelle structure qui
s'appelle royal quitte sa à la clé saint
pierre pour les plus petits également on
a aussi la chance d'avoir huit
city-stade sur l'ensemble de la ville où
les jeunes peuvent faire du skate du
vélo et autres et on à 21h de jeu
bonjour les plumes il ya une attention
particulière qui est portait justement
sur les activités de plus en plus chaque
année parce que les gens partent moins
en vacances
est ce que vous y faites attention c'est
là ça fait partie de la politique de la
ville oui bien sûr la politique de la
ville c'est d'organiser des activités
pour que les jeunes se sentent bien dans
leur ville
y compris pendant les vacances l'été
juste une parenthèse parce qu'on parle
des activités de la ville il ya aussi
jeudi 27 août sur votre commune une
projection de cinéma en plein air avec
le dernier film fantastique et x men
mais ça se fait avec le conseil
départemental et si je vous pose la
question c'est parce que vous êtes
conseillère départementale également
aujourd'hui quelles implications à le
conseil départemental alors le conseil
départemental a lancé cette opération
qui s'appelle les yvelines font leur
cinéma
donc c'est des séances de cinéma public
en plein air gratuites qui sont
proposées aux villes donc il y à une
vingtaine de villes je crois sur le
département qui ont ce dispositif à
elancourt ce sera donc le 27 le 27 août
donc ça se passe à la coulée verte le
lieu va être ouvert à partir de 19h où
les gens vont pouvoir venir pique
en famille ou entre voisins et faire des
petites animations il y aura
l'association da capoeira d'elancourt
qui viendra faire des animations
juste avant la projection du film ça ce
sera le 27 août cette compétence
d'activités proposées sa relève
uniquement des municipalités vous avez
l'appuyer aussi des conseils département
alors les activités pour les jeunes
pendant les périodes de vacances n'est
pas une compétence du département c'est
une compétence communale donc le
département appuie les communes en
lançant des dispositifs tels que les ive
et ils font leur cinéma et le propose
aux villes qui veulent bien le les
mettons en oeuvre une capture vous reste
en plateau on va regarder ce qui se
passe à présent à trappes on va
commencer par ce sujet réalisé lors du
lancement de l'opération plages avec
sephora namani et elodie moines pour les
images depuis lundi la plage prend ses
quartiers autour de la piscine et
jacques moncaut attrape pour la septième
édition
cette opération qui propose du
beach-volley des activités aquatiques ou
encore des châteaux de sable pour se
sentir en vacances sans bouger qu'ont
déjà beaucoup d'adeptes
on profite du soleil et
ils ont fait des châteaux de sable les
enfants ce qu'ils n'ont pas eu la chance
d'aller en vacances on sent à peu près
comme à la plage et puis les parents on
discute entre nous qui compte que c'est
une bonne idée
c'est une chance pour ceux qui sont par
ailleurs en vacances les enfants en
profitent
on retrouve leurs camarades de classe
n'est pas très longtemps que ça arrêter
les petits sont avec nous les plus
grands au club ados et les plus grands
16 ans ils sont dans l'eau et nous on
est tranquille et discuter avec les
copines qu'on n'a pas eu l'occasion
d'aller plus loin que paris donc on en
profite à trappes plage de drap 800
tonnes de sable ont été déplacées pour
l'occasion afin de pouvoir profiter de
la plage sur son transat
installés confortablement sous un
parasol il sera possible de bronze et
accra plage cet été jusqu'au 8 août à
l'irb et lui attrape comment s'est
construit ce programme justement là
aussi implication des services de la
ville des associations on en est à la
septième édition
le projet a vu le jour en 2009 le
constat vous l'avez fait tout à l'heure
beaucoup de familles de jeudi bien de
familles pas uniquement des jeunes des
familles entières n'ont pas les moyens
de partir en congés en vacances à
trappes pendant la période estivale
donc on a estimé qu'il était nécessaire
de leur proposer le meilleur à proximité
leur domicile dont on a pas la mer on
n'a pas la plage à trappes mais on a une
belle piscine dans le complexe jacques
moncaut et on a décidé de faire venir
800 tonnes de sable pour mettre un petit
bout de plage un petit bout un petit
bout de ceux de ciel bleu est on à la
piscine également qui est ouverte pour
permettre aux gens de bronze et de
profiter de des animations qui sont
proposées
c'est une trentaine d'agents au
quotidien qui sont mobilisés sur la
plage et on offre un panel de services
des plus petits des pré ados disposant
qui sont gérés par le service enfance en
passant par les adolescents et un club
ados pour les 11-17 et ensuite on a des
activités avec les centres
socioculturels avec le service des
sports qui animent au quotidien la plage
ça permet de créer du lien aussi de
permettre le dialogue au sein de la
population
vous l'aviez âgées abandonnées des
familles qui ont témoigné juste avant on
a toutes les générations qui sont
présentes des personnes âgées des
familles des parents on permet également
aux parents de profiter d'un moment de
détente puisque leurs enfants sont pris
en charge dans les clubs qui sont
ouverts pour ça sur la plage
et on a un grand espace un solarium de
4000 mètres carrés qui permet à chaque
génération de se retrouver et puis
partagé on a pour sa part choisi de
modifier un peu les horaires vous avez
peut-être constaté qu'on a décidé
d'ouvrir jusqu'à 20 heures tous les
soirs on organise également une nocturne
par semaine auparavant c'était bi
hebdomadaire cette fois on fait chaque
semaine le vendredi soir et puis on a
des semaines thématiques avec des
soirées thématiques qui permettrait à
tout le monde de profiter jusqu'à 22
heures des activités proposées
donc là c'est sûr l'opération plages
trappe plage mais en dehors de ce rendez
vous il ya aussi des sorties qui sont
organisées pour les familles pour les
parents toute activité culturelle
spécifique
on prépare la rentrée également il ya
des ateliers pour ça qu'elle est un
petit peu ce dispositif plus global
il ya énormément de choses qui sont
proposés à trappes pendant l'été
effectivement les services ne s'arrête
pas pendant l'été chez nous on a un
dispositif qui connaît un très grand
succès qui contribue à mettre le pied à
l'étrier aux jeunes qui cherchent du
boulot notamment en leur permettant dans
le cas d'un dispositif qui s'appelle une
semaine d'efforts pour financer son
projet de travailler une semaine en
partenariat souvent avec les bailleurs
pour rénover une cage d'escalier faire
un travail d'information chez les
habitants sur le tri sélectif pour
également embellir les l'environnement
quotidien des habitants
il y en a 120 jeunes chaque année qui en
profitent non 60 pendant l'été travail
pendant cinq jours sont rémunérés hun
sen travail salarié et/ou une première
expérience dans leur cv
donc ça fait partie des choses que l'on
propose pendant l'été on est également
de séjour humanitaire de solidarité
internationale des chantiers là en
islande l'autre en thaïlande
oui on les fait partir loin d'être à
rennes fleuve pour quelques-uns dont une
douzaine de jeunes qui vont profiter on
également séjours linguistiques qui
s'organise pendant l'été en espagne on
en organise trois dans l'année il y en a
un qui part pendant l'été et puis on a
des stages une diversité de stages vtt
sport à l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur de
la ville qui sont ouverts pour cent
cinquante jeunes sur la commune de
trappes pendant le mois de juillet et au
mois d'août
ensuite on prépare la rentrée vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure puisqu'on a
un séjour fin août d'euros mobilisation
dans le cadre scolaire
on a un très bon partenariat dans la
ville de trappes avec l'éducation
nationale on permet à des jeunes de
réaliser le brevet au mode d'avril et on
perd mais également avant la rentrée
scolaire au mois de septembre soit dans
une semaine de partir en auvergne se
remettre à niveau reprendre le rythme de
l'école également ce pas évident pour
les enfants de se réhabituer à se lever
tôt à se coucher tôt également et on
leur permet de profiter d'activités
diverses tout en étant remis dans le
bain de l'école à la fin de l'année
j'insiste sur une petite animation qu'on
organise dans le cadre de trappes la
juste une petite nouveauté un
partenariat avec la police nationale
dans le cadre du club ados nos jeunes
vont avoir des séances ou des changes
avec la police avec le commissariat de
trappes
je remercie d'ailleurs le commandant a
rendu rennes qui est très mobilisé
globalement dans nos partenariats mais
là spécifiquement on a un stage de
sensibilisation sur la sécurité pour les
deux roues une deuxième séance pour
expliquer le la nature les raisons qui
justifient les contrôles d'identité on
sait que c'est un sujet de crispation
entre les jeunes et la police
et puis pour finir les métiers au sein
de la police nationale qui vont être
présentés à nos jeunes
ça parle mais dialogue les rues
l'actualité récente que jamais je pense
que c'est le dialogue entre la police et
la population est nécessaire en
particulier avec les jeunes donc on a
travaillé cela avec le directeur de
cabinet de la ville de trappes la police
nationale et les services de la commune
on va proposer ça aux jeunes pendant
l'été un dispositif important il ya un
budget spécifique qui est alloué comment
sur train sur trois plages et sur toutes
les activités dans un projet global de
près de deux cent mille euros
je vous disais une trentaine d'agents
mobilisés on a quelques financements
mais qui reste relativement modeste on à
la région qui nous donne vingt mille
euros et la politique de la ville qui
nous donne quinze mille euros
mais on a dépensé importante mais en
même temps on a une influence
extrêmement importante c'est près d'un
trapy sur trois qui fréquentera plage
pendant l'été c'est vous dire le
le besoin auquel ça répond l attente de
la population c'est une dernière chose
elle est importante
en dehors de trappes l'âge mais les
habitants eux mêmes prennent des
initiatives
on a des fêtes de quartier qui
fleurissent un peu partout la 17 18 19
on a trois fêtes de quartier qui
s'organise dans les rangs trois jours
sur quatre fêtes de quartier sur la
ville et ses quelque chose de
relativement sain et positif quand les
habitants eux-mêmes s'organise pour
faire la fête en bas de chez eux
un peu comme la fête des voisins en
sollicitant la municipalité pour les
autorisations et un appui logistique
mais les habitants souvent des jeunes
organise la fête pour toutes les
générations
vous parlez de trappes plage de la
piscine notamment il y aura sans doute
des allemands courtois aussi qui vont
fréquenter cette piscine parce que la
saisine d'oisien est il mort passe bien
mais cette piscine de mort pas qui est
qui est fermée aujourd'hui pour raisons
d'insalubrité avec ou non des travaux à
la clé mais est encore des études en
cours là dessus tout simplement ça veut
dire que on peut plus rendre à la
piscine de maurepas pour il encourt vous
avez trouvé un accord avec saint cyr
l'école récemment avec la piscine de
saint cyr au niveau tarifaire voilà
absolument on a passé un accord avec la
mairie de saint cyr qui autorise donc
l'accès à la piscine de saint cyr à tous
les élans courtois un tarif préférentiel
qui est le tarif qui est réservé aux
sorcières est un sacré roi j'en sais
rien mais ça fait ça rien voilà donc les
îles en cours à l'école avec ses sinon
ils vont mettre fin d'accord oui au
sérieux donc
donc les élans contre avons pu voir
quand même avoir accès à la piscine la
piscine cet été une dernière question
qui va s'adresser à tous les deux depuis
vingt ans les colonies de vacances
connaisse une baisse régulière de leurs
fréquentations en réponse le
gouvernement s'est fixé pour objectif de
faire émerger une nouvelle génération de
séjour est ce que c'est une bonne idée
vous pensez est ce que ça peut se mettre
en oeuvre favoriser ses colonies de
vacances alors les séjours les colonies
de vacances au sein des communes
on revient toujours au même problème qui
est un problème budgétaire avec les
baisses de dotations de l'état la mise
en place des rythmes scolaires et j'en
passe et des meilleurs les communes ont
de moins en moins de moyens pour mettre
ce dispositif en place l'année dernière
sur elancourt il y avait
on avait été organisé des séjours et
c'est vrai qu'on avait moins de demandes
que les autres années de toute façon
donc je pense que le pouvoir d'achat des
familles ne permet pas malheureusement
pour certaines familles même à des prix
très très très avantageux d'un voyou il
faut des budgets pourraient balayer
toute façon intense n'a pas ce genre de
problème on a effectivement beaucoup de
colonies fin de séjour organisé par la
commune elle même par ses agents tout au
long de l'année en particulier sur l'été
et on a le plus souvent plus d'inscrits
plus de demandeurs que de places
disponibles
donc ça marche plutôt bien chez nous et
on diminue pas l'offre parce que le
besoin existe et il est très fort même
si ça a effectivement un coût pour les
collectivités mais après c'est une
question prioritaire
merci à vous de programmation détaillée
sur les sites internet de vos communes
respectives et long cours est rappelé
pour savoir comment vous occuper pendant
l été si vous habitez du côté de
montigny-le-bretonneux la municipalité
aussi pardon a pensé à vous à
l'opération était en sable a été
reconduite l'été est lancé à montigny le
bretonneux
si vous ne partez pas en vacances un
coin de plage à l'ambiance balnéaire
vous attend sur le parking du gymnase
alain colas plusieurs activités
sportives et culturelles cours de zumba
ou encore soirée à la hawaïenne sont au
programme pendant tout l'été
cette animation et les mises en place en
fait pour les familles et être
pratiquement essentiellement et puis
pour les jeunes c'est pour leur
permettre de trouver un petit coin de un
petit coin de plage pour ceux qui n'ont
pas la chance de partir et puis pour
ceux qui ont la chance de partir pour
pouvoir prolonger aussi leur leurs
vacances
on a des retours très positifs donc
l'année dernière on a vu une
fréquentation entre vingt et vingt-cinq
mille personnes à peu près donc déjà les
gens sont contents déjà 2
de cet événement et disent que d'année
en année ça c'est off ça ça devient de
plus en plus jolie donc on est content
on sait qu'on va dans le bon sens saint
lô en fait vous faites le tour par là
bas un endroit pour se réunir en famille
et partager entre amis
25 animateurs seront présents chaque
jour pour animer les activités proposées
dont des séances de chico de tai chi et
de yoga convient ici en principe la
petite commence un petit peu tout seul
moi je m'installe et après je passe
souvent une bonne partie de l'après midi
avec el atrache à total d'ailleurs on a
gagné l'an dernier à un petit prix pour
le plus beau château tas de l'été pour
les personnes qui peuvent pas forcément
partir en week-end
ça permet d'occuper les enfants l'accès
est libre
vous pouvez en profiter jusqu'au 23 août
et nous terminons en musique avec abou
originaire de trappes il vient d'ouvrir
un studio de répétition à versailles
c'est un artiste local et nous l'avons
rencontré le reportage sur les i
machines et de mélanie poquet studio 223
comme une référence au mali et 223 c
l'indicatif téléphonique de ce pays et
c'est aussi le nom du nouveau studio
d'enregistrement ouvert dans le quartier
saint louis à versailles par un peu
d'orgueil à promouvoir des parties ce
que moi même c'est à dire autant les
artistes locaux
les coups de coeur que moi j'aurais
aussi éventuellement mais aussi au
niveau de l'international compte
beaucoup développée en fait les artistes
au niveau du magny autre mali trappe et
versailles l'artiste propose dans ce
studio tous les outils pour du mixage du
mastering et de l'enregistrement à 25
euros de l'heure ces tarifs sont très
compétitifs il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
musiciens en herbe du fait qu'on a
également en plus de ça au rez de
chaussée une école de musique
donc il fait batterie plus guitare à 39
ans l'ancien ingénieur informaticien
reconverti musicien depuis plus de 15
ans écrit une nouvelle page de sa vie
professionnelle lui qui a lancé le
mouvement à free pop qui mêle hip hop
racines africaines et culture populaire
un courant musical est bien plus que
cela un mélange de partage et de mixité
j'écrirai mon meilleur texte a rententi
tout comme le promet tri
si tu peux
dubos testament marqué mon temps par
millimètre de la plume avec mes notes
s'est enquéri à travers lui au niveau de
mon style musical aujourd'hui j'essaye
d'évoluer le but étant un petit peu
comment la stromae c'est à dire qu'on va
pouvoir me retrouver autant dans du
reggae du hip hop de la world music de
la variété mehr fait un petit peu à la
sauce à freeport de la musique club est
le frère d'un autre trappistes célèbre
issa doumbia ne ment pas de projet à
vous voudrez aussi développer sa propre
ligne de vêtements
c'est la fin de cette édition du 8
juillet je vous retrouve demain jeudi
pour un nouveau point sur l'actualité
locale tout de suite sur télé fils
kiosques le magazine hebdomadaire dédié
à la culture très belle soirée